aaron savali welcome back june 21st his
last start he will be the starting
pitcher three on the left side of the
infield now for byron buxton
broke his back
yucheng or rather owen miller going back
and he makes a terrific play dynamite
effort by owen miller if that ball goes
over the other shoulder it's tough to
pivot around but he had it the whole way
and just able to make a quick adjustment
right there as they put the hand up
right at the last minute that's a fine
running catch with your back to the
infield
two strikes on josh he swings and laces
a base hit to center field
so a two on line drive rocket up the
middle
good pitch and a curveball struck him
out and aaron sivali puts up a goose egg
in the first john gantz will make his
fourth start as a twin and gant he has
gotten better and better start by start
last time out against the cubs he gave
up two runs in five innings curveball
slider
shorter slider they wants to call a
cutter and then a
split finger
on the outside edge
there's a
another change of a swing and a miss
reyes strikes out that ends the
cleveland first inning better ops
when he's hitting lead off
get hard to the corner
and ramirez
will cut it off and sono held to a
single and the indians lost too big a
chunk
of their rotation this year
but it's great to see savali back and
he's looking sharp here tonight couple
of k's
this is this is big league stuff he's
got there's no there's no doubt in my
mind
and a change up for strike three another
good inning another hitless inning for
john cann
now the one-two delivery
curveball got him swinging no score
middle of the third
and the 2-0 from gam
hard hit ground ball to third backhanded
by donaldson from foul territory owen
beats it out for an infield single and
the indians have their first hit of the
night lead off man aboard for the first
time
could be two
there's one and two a double play and
that'll bring them strong with the bases
empty
2-2 count here
and a ground ball on the right side
what's wrong with that
you see he
and that's his job is to get on base
and a smash in the left field by andreas
ximena's
miles holds it second rooker was able to
get to it quickly and so you've got
something brewing now with your best
hitter coming to the plate and the bases
are now loaded that sets up inside the
3-1 pitch a high fly ball left center
field buckston back with the play near
the wall he's got it to end the inning
now byron knew he had a play the entire
time some drama there on that swing from
reyes but buxton makes the catch
commands the baseball 37 strikes out of
his first 50 pitches how about that
wow swinging a miss oak held on foul tip
hedges hangs on
they go one two three nine in a row
retired by savali
there's a good change up getting a swing
and a miss two away kepler's nine for
nine in stolen base attempts this year
missing inside kepler goes and is in
easily under the high throw by hedges so
now 10 for 10 for kepler when the twins
get a runner in scoring position three
and two to count on rooker here's the
pitch to it
called strike three on the outside
corner good fastball that time from
aaron savali
get him looking fastball painted the
inside corner that was a perfect pitch
that's his sixth strikeout of the night
one ball no strikes
ground ball up the middle it's going to
sneak through for a base hit kepler
going to be waved around
the throw to the plate is not in time
twins lead one to nothing on an anderton
simmons single up the middle so the walk
stolen base two strikeouts and there's a
cni single up the middle and the twins
are on the board no balls and two
strikes to straw head just doesn't run
well at all he's at first and the 02.
swung out of miss got him nice pitch
went to the changeup and again effective
when he's ahead of the count is fifth
strikeout he comes back with good
pitches you don't see that all the time
strikes him out two down
got him
and gant finishes off the fifth with a
strikeout three straight strikeouts
preserving
a one-nothing win
now the 2-2 delivery
swing and a miss good change-up that's
that new split change stefan
is featuring
beautiful got him to swing and miss
inning over last year jorge threw the
three fastest pitches
on this staff
and the pitch swung out of miss got him
in 97.
so there's out number one that's four
strikeouts in a row
for the twins pitchers one strike to
chang
donaldson knocks it down comes up firing
and got him sono
with a stretch at the end
and although has his hitless scoreless
sixth inning on the left-hander to face
rooker rorvette and then simmons twins
by one first pitch he's swinging a fly
ball right center field and deep back it
goes deep it goes and gone
welcome to the game alex young and
welcome to home run number seven brett
rooker two-nothing twins in the seventh
rooker to the right of dead center field
first pitch ready
and young a guy that came in with an era
near nine in seven games pitching with
cleveland
worker adding to that as the twins now
lead two nothing on a first pitch
fastball that is 8-9-1
and the 1-1 pitch lined to right field
that's caught by cino with a leap that
was ticketed i thought for right field
but miguel playing off the line and deep
jumped up and caught it
and robbed a hit maybe a double there
for miller one out
really good split
another 3-2
and that was the best one he's thrown
yes it is marlo hale likes the match-up
here righty-lefty
and the one two swag and a miss and
donnie goes and a change up so mania
following that pep talk from west
strikes out jimenez
and cleveland leaves a man and jose
ramirez will lead it off
a little number back toward the mound
tough play for dealmart he can't make
the play
ramirez with that all out hustle and the
leadoff man aboard tiger under the plate
[Applause]
fastball got him reached back for 94 and
blew it by him a big strikeout one away
driven a deep left field
get up
off the wall
jose ramirez in the third oscar mercado
absolutely barreled that ball up
and his double has runners at second and
third with two down oh so close it's so
hard that jose couldn't score but you've
got the tying run
in scoring position with two outs
two-nothing twins the 3-2 swag gonna
miss strike three on a slow curve ball
and chang strikes out swinging and
cleveland leaves two more in scoring
position arrives over three with a one i
think it's probably going to be a split
and a rise dumps one to right that is
into the corner a fair ball simmons
rounding second on his way to third
being windmilled home and he will score
and rise is safe at third with a triple
there's just not a spot that parker
could throw that split with two strikes
that can keep arise from getting the big
out of the bat to it scoring standing up
for first base on the triple by rise two
and two the count on the left-handed
swinging pin shooter bobby bradley twins
three cleveland nothing ninth inning
and the 2-2 he struck him out swinging
and the ball game is over and the twins
have won three straight games shutting
out cleveland three to nothing
you